This is the story of an
evolutionary trap.
A trap laid by people, but which led to the
demise of thousands of butterflies.
What went wrong?
And can we stop it happening again?
We start in a meadow in Nevada
with the Edith's Checkerspot butterfly.
Like many butterflies, the Edith's Checkerspot has favourite plants on which to lay its eggs.
in this meadow the butterflies' first
choice is called the Blue-eyed Mary.
The butterflies lay their
eggs in the spring.
A fortnight later they hatch,
and the ravenous
caterpillars feed for two weeks, before
the plant starts to die back
and the caterpillars
enter a dormant state.
Next spring,
when the Blue-eyed Marys regrow,
the caterpillars wake up,
gorge themselves,
and build a cocoon.
Then they finally emerge as a butterfly.
This cycle has been going on
for generations,
until humans brought in cattle.
And with the cows came an
invasive plant called Ribwort Plantain.
The Plantain doesn't die back in the
summer like the Blue-eyed Mary
so caterpillars which hatch on the
Plantain have longer to eat before
entering their dormant state, helping
more of them survive to adulthood.
What's more, a mother butterfly with a
preference for Plantain
is likely to pass that preference
on to her caterpillars.
The evolutionary trap was set.
Gradually, the whole population of butterflies
became dependent on the Plantain,
abandoning the
Blue-eyed Mary entirely.
The butterflies did well,
for a while...
Until in 2005,
the cattle ranchers moved out.
Without the cows, grass quickly grew,
engulfing the Plantain
and hiding it from
the butterflies.
Without the Plantain to lay their eggs on
the butterflies were done for.
They couldn't adapt fast enough
to switch back to the Blue-eyed Mary.
Within a year they all died.
For four years there were no more
Edith's Checkerspots in the meadow.
But that wasn't the end...
Luckily, butterflies from other meadows which
never abandoned the Blue-eyed Mary
moved in, and the population
is now recovering.
This is the first time that this kind of
evolutionary trap has been recorded,
and around the world, more traps
like it could already be set
waiting to go off.
Conservationists normally look for
problems when humans arrive,
but this trap was sprung
when people left.
It's important to remember that
humans make changes quickly,
but evolution needs longer to react.
And the researchers hope
that the tale of the Edith's Checkerspot
will act as a warning